the 2011 Fukushima nuclear disaster in
Japan was the second worst nuclear
accident in history after Chernobyl more
than a decade later the story is the
subject of a new Netflix drama series
called the days which debuts tomorrow
the Meltdown still haunts Japan and the
cleanup will take decades now a plan to
release a massive amount of treated
radioactive water into the Sea of Japan
is stirring new fear and controversy
Elizabeth Palmer visited the site to
find out what's at stake
that swept ashore in 2011 caused one of
the worst nuclear accidents in history a
meltdown of the Fukushima reactors
more than a decade later Engineers are
still working to remove radioactive
debris and meanwhile another problem is
piling up in these tanks experts for
tepco the company in charge explained
they've collected so much radioactive
water from rain and runoff over the
years they kept having to add tanks to
contain it now 12 years in these tanks
are almost full of water more than a
million tons of it and tepco says the
only solution is to start getting rid of
it by piping it into the sea next to the
plant
for Haru Ono who's been fishing this
ocean all his life that is an outrage
it's not a garbage stump he tells me
they say it's safe but the consequences
could be 50 years down the road
there will be no consequences says tepco
because its technology removes all
radioactive compounds from the water
except one tritium which stays in but is
diluted to meet International standards
so even when the water is piped back
into the sea tepco says fish from
Fukushima will be safe to eat and it's
raising some inside the nuclear plant to
prove it in this lab our fish flounder
that are living in water with the same
level of radiation as the water that is
going to be released back into the sea
the tritium certainly hasn't affected
their appetites these are Lively ones
and tests show that back in normal
seawater they flush it out of their
systems
the international atomic energy agency
broadly backs the tritium-laced water
release but will consumers actually eat
the fish
unlikely says who is now looking at the
end of his livelihood
the human cost of the Fukushima meltdown
will weigh on Japan for decades to come
and so will the dollar cost of the
cleanup nearly 90 billion dollars so far
and Counting for CBS mornings I'm
Elizabeth Palmer in Fukushima Japan
when it meets International standards
you gotta ask yourself what exactly are
those standards